你从今天就想好我怀孕，
我生孩子，
我为的是什么？
如果说我就因为我自己年纪到了，
哎呀，
我就想要有一个这样一个社会身份了，
那你就不要指望太多，
不要指望婆婆付出太多，
我不要指望老公付出太多，
否则的话，
那就是必然会有矛盾的。
我跟我对象呢，
是去年10月份朋友介绍认识的，
我们11月份开始谈的恋爱，
我和她都是在一线城市工作，
她的工作呢是给老板当助理，
我的工作呢是那个自由化妆师，
我俩呢是打算要结婚，
结婚的原因是一月份发现意外怀孕的，
目前我是30岁，
他是33岁，
因为年龄也差不多到了，
就把那个孩子生下来，
准备结婚，
你们就开始聊，
比如说什么彩礼啊，
因为他们家没有房子，
就说今在暂期也可以先不买，
之后如果要计划买的时候呢，
他父母给出个首付，
彩礼呢，
目前是说好的是说20个，
然后三金和钻戒这些要买，
后面给我聊到说因为现在金比较贵，
他跟我沟通说比较贵，
可能买不了特别多给8万块钱，
这个是之前都聊好了的，
年底工作比较忙，
这个钱就一直没有给到，
我在聊好三金跟彩礼之后，
他最近老是就在聊这个钱嘛，
这个地方花钱比较多啊，
那个地方花钱比较多什么的，
我就。
就觉得他可能会把前面的东西看的比较重，
我就会因为这个没有安全感嘛，
然后我就想问问您，
我自己工作呢，
目前我的那个存款大概40个，
但他之前骗过我，
我跟他说我可能就10个左右，
我是想把我自己的老婚前的这些钱归类到一张银行卡里边儿去存个定期，
我就想问他给我的那个彩礼，
我放在我另一张，
现在也一直在常用的一张卡里边，
但那张卡里的钱我都已经转出了，
他给我转过来的话，
这也是会认定为我的婚前财产了，
对吗？
如果没有领结婚证，
我建议你呢这么干，
你自己婚前的这40万呢，
比如你存在建行卡里，
从此就不要动了，
他给你的20万彩礼呢，
比如就存在农行卡里，
也不要动了，
后续你再赚的钱，
你再有的收入领了结婚证了，
比如说你再存在一个招行卡里，
这样的话，
招行卡就作为一个商活的卡，
这样的话其实能区分得开，
万一真的将来有什么问题的话，
哪一笔钱是我自己婚前的40万的存款我能说的清楚，
哪一笔钱是彩礼钱我也能说的清楚，
我把自己的钱放在了一张就刚办的银行卡里边，
结婚证我现在没有领，
因为我是一直在纠结领不领你结婚证这个事儿，
你俩认识的时间说实话没有很长，
人与人之间的相似，
我觉得你定是都有问题，
每个人肯定不可能是。
是完美的，
但我觉得在跟他相处的过程中，
时间没有很长的时候，
也有过几次奔跑嘛，
我会觉得他老是说钱这个事情会比较没有安全感，
然后那个钱我现在就是放在另外了那张卡里边，
我是想让他那个20万转了一张，
就是我之前常用，
但是不是新办的，
这样是不影响的，
对吧，
你以后还常用这张卡吗？
这张卡就像您刚才说的，
因为我经常有听您的课嘛，
我经常开您直播，
然后我自己这张卡我也是打算说之后可能就是就给他存起来，
就也是打算存个定期，
另外我俩要再用，
就比如说我俩婚后的一些他的工资也有沟通，
说每个月给到多少钱给到放在一张卡里边儿，
这张卡我是重新放的卡，
就是跟这两张卡都不混在一块儿啊，
那可以，
那没问题，
那我们俩如果我是不打算领结结婚证的话，
他给我转的这20个也是会归类为我自己的婚前财产吗？
如果没有领结婚证，
就不存在婚前这个概念，
就相当于这个钱呢，
假设有一天你们要分开啊，
但是因为你们共同生育了一个子女，
那如果你能证明这些钱我花到了子女的这个生产啊，
孩子的奶粉钱呀，
我花到了这些当中的话，
他想要呢，
也很难要回去，
我明白，
那就是说如果说领了结婚证，
他就可以认定为是我的婚身财产在20个，
如果没有理的话，
就。
难界定嘛，
比如说后期有一些其他的问题，
现在是目前没有出现什么问题，
就是我比较纠结的点是什么，
他的工作吧，
就是会经常性如时候晚上应酬，
因为他老板的助理嘛，
他会需要陪老板去应酬，
陪客户吃饭，
有时候送老板回去，
晚上会特别晚回来，
我现在又是因为自己的身体状况，
可能因为这个事情有过好几次的争吵，
但这个事情的现状可能目前也改变不了。
我自己的想法是我即便结完婚生完孩子之后，
可能也是想要自己工作上班对我来说比较有安全感，
然后孩子的话，
我是想让说婆婆过来帮忙带，
现在就卡在说我领不领结婚证跟上，
因为我是觉得领完结婚证吧，
后续如果是还有一些其他一系列的问题，
我是一个特别嫌麻烦又极其安全感的人，
我在纠结又有点矛盾，
我个人觉得啊，
领不领结婚证这个事儿都好说，
领或者不领对于你来说区别不是特别大，
但是生不生孩子这个事儿你得想明白，
生孩子这个事情的话呢，
在目前为止，
我自己觉得我应该是还是会生的，
如果婆婆不给你带，
有什么其他的替代方案吗？
就目前为止，
如果说她不给我带，
我好像还没有考虑过这个问题，
但以我自己来带，
我的工作性质来说，
如果真的走到那一步，
我上班是3。
表自由，
我可以选择说请一个人帮忙带，
工作的时候可以出去工作，
平时我机自己带也没有什么特别大的问题。
那你有跟你的未来婆婆相处过吗？
性格合适吗？
合得来吗？
接触过就是只是见过一面，
我觉得一面可能看不太出来吧，
目前接触到没有什么，
就觉得也还行，
挺好。
娘家这边爸爸妈妈能给你帮衬吗？
爸爸妈妈这边是提供不了太多帮助的，
你看30岁啊，
有很多东西的话，
你可能未必能预料得到，
生一个孩子，
养一个孩子所要付出的代价有多大，
要付出的时间精力有多大。
是的，
所实我现在就是比较矛盾的点就在这里，
就是我其实觉得自己没有完全考虑好，
但又觉得你自己的自己身体状况来说呢，
也有了，
就想着说把他生下来，
有了就把他生下来，
你能为孩子带来什么呢？
你能为孩子创造什么呢？
你能为孩子提供什么呢？
我自己是觉得我这么以我自己的工作能力来说，
退1万来，
我问一下你，
你现在的资产状况，
除了有40万的存款之外，
你还有什么？
我只要是有时间工作，
就每年他都能保持一个稳定的正常收入是没问题的。
我问你有房吗？
没有，
那你们当地要买一套房要花多少钱？
当地如果说要买的话，
我俩的计划。
可能会花个100万以内吧，
如果花100万买房的话，
目前来看你俩是没有这个能力的，
对不对？
他父母是有沟通过，
说会帮忙出这个首付的钱，
如果出完首付的钱，
我俩自己还案揭的话，
以我俩自己的目前的收入情况是OK的，
我只能跟你说，
所有的事情，
别人的承诺没有落到实处的时候，
都当他放屁，
比如说你的现在这个男朋友说要给你20万彩礼，
今天就打可以，
但凡是不但是都能，
这个是确定没问题，
我自己一直没办法转，
是因为我自己这部分的钱我没有给他捋清楚，
我工作太忙了，
他是给我转，
然后我一直觉得这个卡我没有办新的卡，
我之前的个卡里面放的是我自己的钱，
我就没有把它全部归避到一张卡是不？
那你今天就让他转，
因为现在你们没有领证，
转到你的卡里就是你的婚前个人财产，
这样的话你加起来就有60万的婚前个人财产，
这样你就从容很多，
哪怕将来有一天分手了，
是吧？
我有60万的存款，
我跟孩子可以度过，
最起码可以平平安安的，
就算我不工作，
就算我请月儿嫂帮我带的话，
我也可以度过三年，
我明白，
那您是建议是结婚，
结婚在这领还是不领啊，
以你的这个情况，
区别不是很大，
因为男方并不是收入别高，
男方如果说收入特别高，
一年能挣三十万四十万的话，
领结婚证对你有好处，
男方收入也不是特别高，
我啊你。
的收入和男方的收入怎么样嘛，
我的收入的话，
我自己正常上班差不多年收入大概在20个左右，
男方的收入怎么样嘛，
他可能会比我稍微少一点，
十几个吧，
你的这个情况领和不领区别不是特别大，
就是当然也得看人家男方的意愿啊，
人家男方出了20万的彩礼，
男方又要给你8万块钱的那个买金子的钱呀什么的，
如果不领结婚证，
人家男方会不会没有安全感，
现在就是因为他们家里一直说要催着去理，
然后我是一直没有拖，
前面也是因为工作嘛没有去，
最近就是我昨天想跟您连线，
就是又在沟通上说要不要去理结婚的这件事儿，
所以我就说想希望您给一下建议，
因为你俩最大的问题是彼此的了解并不是很深，
彼此并不是特别的相爱，
没有很深的了解，
没有很深的信任，
没有很深的感情，
现在我们谈的都是钱，
那我们就谈钱，
从谈钱这个角度来说的话，
你领证和不领证区别不大了，
我我知道我今天讲这个话，
可能直播间有很多人听着都有点摸不着头脑。
龙飞今天为什么讲话这个风格，
好像其实原因是在于，
第一，
他们认识的时间很短，
第二，
他们是没有任何的信任背书的，
他们彼此之间没有很深的信任基础的，
第三，
他们彼此之间也不是说很相。
爱很深，
爱只是因为女的30，
男的33，
年龄到了，
女的怀孕了，
只是因为走到这一步了，
是这样的关系，
那从大数据来看，
这样的关系最后能走下去的概率比较小，
分手的概率比较大，
你能理解这个逻辑吗？
第那什么情况会导致你们两个人离心，
导致你们两个人闹矛盾呢？
可能就是将来孩子的经济支持，
孩子怎么带，
时间精力怎么分配，
大概率消费，
因为这个就是孩子将来你是要比如说要请月嫂啊，
是请1万的还是请2万的呀，
将来这个孩子是母乳啊还是奶粉啊，
奶粉的话是进口的还是国产的呀，
将来孩子比如说要打预防针啊，
是要打收费的还是不收费的呀，
孩子以后这个穿衣服呀，
鞋子袜子啊，
谁来买呀，
以后孩子这个平时谁来带税呀，
谁来负责孩子的接送啊，
你们大概率啥会因为这些问题去产生纠纷，
嗯，
明白了，
您的建议，
如果给的更好的话，
我其实大概有听明白您的意思，
就您的建议说，
其实如果是这样的情况下，
我相议他没有什么太多的感情基础，
其实不删是一个最好的选择，
对吗？
因为你30岁吗？
你不是说是35了，
36了，
37了，
38了。
不是说不生是一个很好的选择，
就是说你自己要想明白，
如果你此时此刻能想明白，
反正我生这个孩子是因为我年龄到了，
我喜欢小孩儿，
我就是给着一个机会了，
我怀孕了，
我就生，
我一切为了我自己，
那么能给我添砖加瓦的，
能给我帮忙的，
都是我的恩人，
包括现在这个男的，
包括将来的婆婆，
都是我的恩人，
都是在给我添砖加瓦的，
你要有这种状态的话，
你就有好日子过。
真的姐妹，
你但凡觉得是我是为别人生了一个孩子，
我生了个孩子给你传宗接代的，
你们怎么付出这么一点儿，
你怎么一点都不上心，
婆婆怎么带孩子这么不小心，
这么不认真的话，
早晚散伙，
这就是心态的问题了。
明白你从今天就想好，
我怀孕，
我生孩子，
我为的是什么？
如果说我就因为我自己年纪到了，
哎呀，
我就想要有一个这样一个社会身份了，
那你就不要指望太多，
不要指望婆婆付出太多，
我不要指望老公付出太多，
否则的话，
那就是必然会有矛盾的，
好的，
那如果说我要生，
那就是您的建议是像刚才一样，
我如果生，
我要怎么去保障我自己的这些利益，
包括就是后续的一些，
我要怎么样去平衡好，
你有什么建议吗？
我觉得你要生的话，
就大大方方的要彩礼啊，
要三金啊，
怎样都要到手上，
然后呢，
也要表现的出来，
对婆婆的感谢，
对老公的感谢，
更多的让他。
不愿意主动的投入到孩子将来的支出，
将来孩子花钱啊什么的，
买奶粉啊，
买尿不湿啊，
买什么东西啊，
另外其实基本上我俩的生活开销都是他在出，
包括房租啊，
包括一些其他的开销，
我觉得都是他在出。
当然还有一点啊，
姐妹今天咱们就是像好姐妹这么聊天啊，
就以后我们也要看人下菜碟，
什么叫看人下菜碟面呢？
你得算一下，
她一年就挣十几个，
所以在养孩子这个过程当中的话，
比如说给孩子买衣服，
买鞋子，
买袜子，
就没必要说超出她的心理预期去买那个几百块的，
就是说看人下菜碟，
看看婆婆是什么条件，
看看老公是什么条件，
在以后养孩子在消费的过程当中的话，
就尽量卡着他们的那个消费的点，
卡着他们的心理预期去消费，
别想着说我孩子一定要读什么私立学校呀，
我孩子一定要说穿什么名牌呀，
孩子一定要喝进口奶粉啊，
都未必卡着人家的心理预期去消费，
这日子就好过。
奈大概清楚了，
谢谢刘天呀，
拜拜，
我跟你们讲刚才跟这个姐妹聊天的这个过程非常值得大家参考，
尤其值得那些还没有生孩子的姐妹去参考，
我直播间有多少姐妹是当你听到我说将来会因为孩子产生的矛盾的那个点的时候，
有没有就每个点都踩？
你了有没有，
就比如说你你将来要是生孩子的时候，
是要住单间还是住泡间，
是要打无痛还是不打无痛，
是要泡还是要顺，
是母乳还是奶粉，
点点都踩中它，
都是矛盾的点，
记得点赞关注哦。